[music]
>> Are there any questions?
In the introduction, we have just done
the introduction.
And we already completed 1 hour.
First page. So, we are on average.
Anyone has any questions?
Regarding the introduction
of the techniques of Islamic public
speech.
Any questions?
We go to page number two.
The important tips.
Body language
is
very, very important. Or very, very,
very, very, very important.
Why is body language
important
in a public speech? Can the body speak?
Can it speak?
No. Yes, it can speak.
Can it instruct?
Yes, it can instruct.
Speaking has got
various meanings in English language.
Literally, if you ask
can it
speak with a verbal voice?
Or a voice, answer is no. But can it
speak? Speak with
So, speak has got different meanings.
Instructions normally people think are
given by the mouth.
But can be given by the hands also.
That's the reason I always prefer
that it's preferable that the talk is
given
without the help of notes. Because with
the notes, my body language is
restricted.
With the notes,
the part which my body is speaking
is not being utilized. If
you noted the day before yesterday,
second day of training, yesterday was a
holiday. In the forms of Dawah,
what you read, you retain 10% of what
you read.
What you hear
is
20%. What you see
is 30%. What you hear and see is 50%.
So, what is the difference of only
hearing my speech
and seeing me while speaking?
Difference is
how much?
Difference is how much?
20%.
Only if you see,
it is
30% retention.
If you see and hear, it is 50%.
Difference is 20%.
So, do you mean to say you only want to
look at the lips?
The research is done with the particular
parameters.
If body language wasn't important,
then hearing and seeing and hearing
would be the
same.
Now, this is a new point I've never told
ever before in any of my training
programs.
I'm conducting this after [snorts] 16
and 1/2 years.
Notes are same.
Little bit here and there.
So, what I spoke day before yesterday on
the second day, it is implemented here.
The research says
30% if you see.
Or if you only hear,
it is
20%.
So, if you hear an audio
and if you see
me
speaking,
then the difference is how much?
30%.
So, if you're hearing an audio tape of
Dr. Zakir Naik
and if you're seeing and hearing a video
of Dr. Zakir Naik, the difference is
30%.
Only seeing and hearing and seeing 20.
Only hearing,
that means
if you hear the audio
and if you see the video audio, the
difference is not 20, the difference is
30.
That means body language carries how
many marks?
How many marks body language carries?
Body language carries
a major portion of the
30% what you're getting. Only hearing is
20%. Hearing while seeing is 50% 30%.
So, body language constitutes not
everything, but the major portion of the
30% what you're getting advantage.
That means watching and hearing is two
and a half times more effective than
only hearing.
That means body language can carry more
marks.
Also than your speech alone. Can carry,
not will carry.
If you're good with that.
Body language
and gestures.
That's the reason I personally
like Sheikh Ahmed Deedat never like
speaking in front of a podium.
Because the podium it restricts your
body.
Not that I have a very good physique.
I'm normal.
Previously I was thin, but now I'm
normal.
I'm not macho.
I'm not a bodybuilder. I don't want to
show my body.
But I want to show the language of my
body.
That's the reason I personally, like
Sheikh Deedat, do not like speaking in
front of a podium.
Not that speaking in front of a podium
is haram. Islamically no difference.
You speak or you don't speak.
But technique-wise, it makes a world of
a difference.
So best is
to speak without notes, without a
podium.
The podium is required mainly for notes.
So if you don't have notes,
podium is not required. But some people
are so used to holding the podium and
speaking that even without notes, if
they don't have a podium,
difficult. They cannot
You can
see
I saw many
people coming day before yesterday.
And I could make out the pros and cons.
Which we'll discuss while we do the
training.
So body language
is very, very important.
And
in body language
there are various different aspects
which some of them will discuss
in the course of time.
Number four, before beginning your
speech
remove any disturbances that may cause
obstruction or hindrance.
Normally when you come
and you find something is disturbing you
remove it.
Sometimes they keep the microphone very
close
to maybe the table
or there's a chair in front of you where
when you do gestures
it will hit the chair.
Put the chair. Now everything is placed
because they know I'm coming.
So the organizer who's calling you
on the stage if he's a professional, you
need not remove anything. Everything is
done.
But most of the times when you go to
Muslim organizations
even after mentioning what you require
you can be sure most of the time it will
not be done.
If there is a table
if you observe when I came what I did
I placed the notes what I required. I
placed the other notes
below the Quran.
Many a time there are things which you
don't require.
No no thing is there but many times you
find there are things
so if I have to go and pick up my notes
and there are many other papers and
books
I'll have to search for my notes.
Normally I don't carry notes but now
because they're giving a point for my
lecture it's there.
So see to it that any disturbance that
is there
you should know your area. There may be
some obstruction here
or you move your microphone away from
the table
or move the table away from the
microphone.
If the recording is going you have to be
careful that have to be in front of the
camera. So any disturbance that is there
which is obstructing you, please remove
it. If the table is cluttered,
if you have to sit on the table and
speak, see to it that the table is
clear. Certain things which is not
required may be there if they have kept
for decoration. If they have kept a
flower vase for decoration, and if it's
causing a problem, remove that also.
Have you called for decoration or called
me for speaking?
That decoration is not more important
than my obstruction.
Me not being obstructed is more
important than decoration.
So, if something is there which the
organizers require and it is not a
hindrance for you, no problem. But
otherwise, as a general rule, clear the
table which I mentioned even on the
first day, that don't keep things on the
table which is not required. What you
require you keep.
You require a pen, you require
a note, whatever. What you don't require
don't keep.
And this is a very important point,
that remove the obstructions which will
cause a hindrance to you.
Does anyone have any questions
on the important points?
Yes, brother Imran.
As-salamu alaykum. Wa alaykum as-salam
wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Things
like podium can help people who are not
so comfortable standing in front of the
crowd.
Brother said that if you use the podium,
it can help a person who's not
comfortable in standing in front of the
crowd. But we have called you here to
make you comfortable without the podium.
Therefore, I said,
it is preferable that the talk is given
without the help of notes. Speak without
a podium to enable the audience to
observe the body language.
The podium will restrict your ability.
It makes you comfortable,
but
does not make you an expert.
For example,
instead of doing revision for 2 hours,
doing revision for 10 minutes is more
comfortable or not?
Yeah, brother Imran. 10 minutes is more
comfortable or 2 hours?
But will 10 minutes be enough, Jihad,
for you to memorize 114 surahs? Okay,
unless you're doing a speech to make
yourself comfortable, then keep a
podium.
If you're going on the stage to make
yourself comfortable, you're going on
the stage to deliver the message.
That's a different question that a
person is unable to speak without notes.
Therefore, I said it is preferable to
speak without notes.
Unfortunately, most of the speakers,
they speak with notes.
But there are many who don't speak. And
Sheikh Deedat
was one of them, mashallah.
He never used notes.
If he had to,
he used to write bullet points.
If you see his talks,
like these are bullet points.
But man, you're the marathon.
He did a speech with about three pages
written in bold letters.
And he picks up.
I don't do that also.
I don't use bullet points.
Only bullet train, no bullet points.
All the [snorts]
All the
>> [music]
[singing]
>> All the
All the
>> [music]
>> All the
All the
>> [music]
>> Our Rahman
Our Rahman
Allah